(soft music)
- Hello, I'm Jonathan Van Ness,
You may know me from
"Queer Eye" on Netflix,
"Getting Curious" on Netflix,
I don't know where you know
me from, but I do know this,
my new book "Love That Story" is out now,
and we're gonna do a
little bit of Q and ASMR.
For our first selection,
it's so hard to whisper,
I'm gonna do it now though.
"Filming "Queer Eye"", oh my
gosh, I can't do it anymore,
"is an incredible opportunity
to delve into someone else's life,
and in every episode, I give
myself over to each hero
and help in any way I can.
I love my job, and I also
love that the show allows me
to be a hairdresser, a comedian,
and an overall entertainer.
But as I've spent more time
in these different careers,
I've realized that I can't
stop and take a moment
for my personal life,
even if I'm going through
something incredibly hard.
When I signed on to "Queer Eye",
I became a beacon of positivity and love.
And there are a lot of times
when I have to maintain that strength
even when I should probably
be taking a little time
to focus that positivity inward,
to let myself mourn
when a tragedy happens,
like what happened to Bug the Second."
I think what I've learned about grief
from exploring grief in this chapter
and then just like the various times
that I've dealt with grief in my life,
is that there's no one way
that we're all going to handle grief.
And it's so individual
for whatever the thing
that we're grieving is, for
wherever we are in our lives,
and I think it's important for us
to like release the judgment
and release the shame around how we grieve
'cause sometimes you just
have to impulse adopt
like two kittens and that's okay.
For our second section,
"My imposter syndrome would sneak up."
Oh my gosh, I made it five words.
"On me most often while
researching different cities
I was scheduled to perform in.
I planned to talk about
the venues. I'd be at,
find out what the comedy
scene was like there
and incorporate a little
local flare into my set.
But then I think about
how many other comedians
had spent their whole lives
trying to do the same thing,
but never got the chance.
At smaller venues, where I was booked
alongside more established comedians,
I'd sometimes get paranoid
that they were giving serious attitude,
like who is this blank?
- [Producer] You can say it.
- Oh, who is this (beep)
unscripted nobody from "Queer Eye?
He doesn't deserve to be here."
Much in the way that
I look at Oksana Baiul
for her gold medal,
Nancy was robbed and I
don't care who knows it."
Thank you for coming to our Q and ASMR,
with me, Jonathan Van Ness,
my book "Love That Story" is available now
at jonathanvanness.com/book.
Yay, or wherever you get your books, ah.
(soft music)